verra dit d'arrêter de me dire que tu
n'as rien fait ils m'ont pris à personne
ici je sais ce que tu attends ta soeur
on va bien acceptes qui s'est passé
qu'est ce que tu as fait baver
de quoi elle parle cette histoire un
type entre chez les gens ils tuent les
parus et le parc des filles et il reste
avec elle et les cadavres des parents
jamais écrire des histoires
[Musique]
insi dancing ghost landes et de loin
votre livre le plus personnel c'est un
best-seller tout le monde adore tout le
monde t'aime je sais pas d'où vient ton
talent ma chérie qu'est ce que tu fais
ici
cette capacité à créer des univers bien
à toi la vraie question c'est pourquoi
avez vous écrit ce livre pour ne pas
devenir dingue continuer à revivre ce
qui s'est passé cette nuit
tu vas me laisser mourir tout ça elle
n'aurait pas dû rester dans cette maison
y a personne ici il n'y a personne tu
entends je sais ce que tu attends ta
soeur
mon briserez que ma rue s'amuse avec
tous du coup prend ce constat qu'est ce
que tu as fait accepte ce qui s'est
passé depuis
baj
[Musique]